okay so I want to update you about the
coinbase
hack situation yesterday I told you that
several thousand dollars in
cryptocurrency were stolen from the
David Pakman show held on coinbase I
explained to you that in working a
support ticket with coinbase they
publicly asked on Twitter for me to send
them our support ticket number which of
course I should not have done but in
retrospect a company that appears to
take security so seriously I incorrectly
and stupidly assumed that anything that
they would ask of me would be sort of
logical within the context of security
protocol without retelling the entire
story we have our entire account meaning
including the cryptocurrency that was
not stolen locked up right now I have
not yet had any resolution as to whether
we will be partially or fully
compensated for the stolen funds there's
been an outpouring of emails from our
audience to coinbase I mentioned
yesterday two ways that our audience
could reach out politely of course one
is through Twitter the two accounts are
at coin base and at coin base support
everybody who tagged me in as well
either at de Pakman or at David Pakman
show
I've been retweeting and trying to get
them moving on this people have also
been contacting coinbase via press at
coin based comm and support at coin
based comm I actually did get a message
yesterday saying that they had escalated
our case to the top level of security
they asked me some questions I
immediately responded and today I got an
email from them saying we haven't heard
back from you about this meaning that
while I was under the impression that
over the last 24 hours they were
continuing to work the case based on the
information I provided they said they
never got my email and they've just been
waiting around for me to email them so
sadly this is going even slower than I
hope that it would but I'm going to keep
you posted about this one way or the
other in terms of if and when we are
given access again to the cryptocurrency
that was not stolen which would be
really really good for us number two I
will keep you posted about whether
we will be in anyway compensated for the
the stolen hacked money I do want to say
we're not running any crowdfunding
campaigns or fundraisers of any kind
I've started to get emails from people
saying David there's a GoFundMe campaign
that claims that it's you raising money
because of what happened with the
coinbase hack or there's an IndieGoGo
that is raising money because of what
happened we have not done any fundraiser
we are not doing any campaign we are not
working with anyone that we've
authorized to run any of those campaigns
multiple campaigns have popped up
claiming that that's what they are
none are associated with us we are
reporting every single one we see you
can do the same and you know people know
that if they want to support us its
membership its patreon its YouTube
sponsorship we're running any
fundraisers it's not us unclear whether
or not those gun GoFundMe pages are
being run in good faith - I have no idea
we don't know it's right bazaar it's a
weird thing to do there may be people
who are running these with the idea that
any money they raise they will send to
me it would have been logical to tell me
about that and to coordinate some of
them didn't even have my name spelled
correctly which really was a red flag to
me that they were planning on giving us
the money others I mean maybe maybe some
of them plan to take the money I have no
idea but if you want to help it's not
through GoFundMe ok patreon.com slash
david pakman show join pakman.com . i
don't know how else i can say that we
are not running any fundraisers
whatsoever and you know this is not good
for us so i do hope that we have some
good news about it soon and i have no
reason to think coinbase is acting in
bad faith with us at all i hope that
they investigate properly that they do
the right thing that they reinstate our
access to our account after all we're
the victims here but i am a little
concerned that 24 hours pass during
which i assumed that they were working
on our case at the highest level and
they just didn't get our email or it was
routed to the wrong security specialists
i mean really really disastrous the
video you just watched was made possible
by support from you please go to
patreon.com slash david pakman show you
can make a pledge of as little as $1 per
month and every dollar helps to support
the work
we're doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which has been really
bad